a White House officials dismissive
comment about Senator John McCain's
cancer fight is adding to a debate about
torture and Gina asked Bill's nomination
to run the CIA a source tells CBS News
the official said in a closed-door
meeting that McCain's opposition to
Haspel does not matter because quote
he's dying anyway
ed O'Keefe is on Capitol Hill with the
newest evidence that Senator McCain and
president and the president don't get
along at good morning good morning John
earlier this week Senator McCain said he
opposed president Trump's pick to lead
the CIA setting Gina Haskell's previous
work on the so-called enhanced
interrogation program during the Bush
era that opposition revives a long
simmering feud between the president and
the Republican senator senator I I I
don't believe that torture works Senator
John McCain this week rejected the
nomination of Gina Haspel saying her
role in overseeing the use of torture by
Americans is disturbing a source tells
CBS News that at an internal White House
meeting Thursday special White House
assistant Kelley Sadler said McCain's
opinion on Haspel doesn't matter because
he's dying anyway the Arizona Republican
who's battling brain cancer was held as
a prisoner for five and a half years
during the Vietnam War and tortured the
fact is was John McCain it worked on
John during an appearance on Fox
Business Network Thursday retired Air
Force Lieutenant General Thomas
McInerney
a trump supporter falsely claimed
torture worked on McCain that's why they
call him songbird John but there is no
evidence McCain ever gave up useful
information to his captors I don't give
a damn what the president United States
wants to do President Trump and Senator
McCain have disagreed about the use of
enhanced interrogation
we will not waterboy we will not they
said mr. Trump I'd like you to answer
the question how do you feel about water
party I said I feel great about it
so the campaign trail you have john
mccain mr. trump didn't hold back his
feelings towards mccain i like people
that weren't captured okay i hate to
tell you
mccain continues the feud in his new
book by criticizing the president and
calling and comparing mr. Trump to a
despot on Twitter Cindy McCain responded
to Sadler writing may I remind you my
husband has a family seven children and
five grandchildren and we should point
out that former Air Force officer used
to be a contributor to the Fox networks
but both the business and news channels
now say he'll no longer be invited on
their air gale alright thank you very
much Cindy McCain's comment but said all
in perspective remember people who
you're dealing with here yeah well one
should remember too that Senator McCain
was captured during a war in which
President Trump received five deferments
from when his plane was shot down we
should when he was in captivity he
passed up early release which was
offered to him and we should also just
to try to get people to reflect maybe on
something else you think about what
Kelly Sadler said John McCain when he
was an early senator used to go visit
somebody who was also in a terminal
situation battling Parkinson's disease
mo Udall Democratic congressman and and
Michael Lewis wrote a great piece about
McCain's time he spent with that
Democratic congressman as he was in a
Veterans Hospital it's an it's a
counterpoint to the insensitive remarks
made about his ability and kindness
matters and we seem to keep forgetting
that